finally tonight it's Friday that means
notable quotables may there be peace may
God bless this embassy violence of the
problem and not part of the solution
Heavenly Father I'm not a bigot I'm not
an extremist ms-13 these are animals now
it seems at times that we live in an age
of grim relativism if we do not confront
the crisis of ethics and integrity if
that American democracy as we know it is
entering its twilight years we have a
great relationship he asked me if I'd
look at ZTE what about jobs in America
mr. president I think we'll actually
have a good relationship assuming we
have the meeting I've got a lot fewer
rebounds than Dennis Rodman but I did
get to spend a great deal time with
Chairman Kim
let the people read it for themselves
and draw their own conclusions some
leaks exist to hurt I guess colleagues
is using the media to shove each other
my wounds have kind of started to heal
this is what the Hawaii National Guard
is worried about lava covering roads
you'll never watch sports the same way
I'm taking the Warriors plus the one and
a half Prince Charles will walk the
American bride down the aisle that
Palace confirmed this morning I would
say introverts of the world unite but is
not not going the meeting that would
mean I have to leave home mr. speaker
what the hell is wrong with this place
that is just so obvious Laurel and not
yeni all right one week thanks for
inviting us into your home tonight
that's it for this special report